[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
8h30 serait laissé l'interview ce matin
c'est avec François Bayrou bonjour
bonjour vous êtes président du MoDem
maire de Pau notamment également au
commissaire en plat on va en parler la
France n'accueillera pas de migrants de
l'anpedouza ESCA digérald Darmanin hier
soir au 20h de TF1 a-t-il raison le
ministre de l'Intérieur de répéter ce
mot de fermeté fermeté fermeté
le visage de la fermeté les
gouvernements les uns après les autres
tous les gouvernements successifs savent
qu'il faut le faire pour ne pas donner
le sentiment que la France est un pays
qui ne fait pas respecter ses propres
lois mais ça veut dire ce qui se passe
en Italie Adrien jade est très très
fascinant
voilà une chef du gouvernement madame
Mélanie qui se fait lire contre l'Europe
qui dit nous on va régler nous-mêmes nos
problèmes on n'a pas besoin de l'Europe
pour tout ça c'est nous qui allons
fermer nos peurs qu'elles ont rendre
inaccessible les côtes nous avons des
armées nous avons une marine elle a
échoué elle en appelle alors et puis
qu'est-ce qui se passe au bout de très
peu de moi ce qui se passe c'est que les
Italiens s'aperçoivent le gouvernement
italien s'aperçoit et toute l'Europe
s'aperçoit et le bassin méditerranéen
s'aperçoit que c'est impossible que ce
n'est pas vrai que cette affirmation
cette cette
promesse de démonstration de force qui a
été dit et répété sur laquelle la chef
du gouvernement italien s'est fait élire
cette promesse est intenable
extrêmement en France que dit-elle
madame Meloni elle dit il n'y a que
l'Europe qui puisse m'aider à m'en
sortir qui puisse nous aider nous
peuples italien nous en sortir
d'abord c'est une leçon pour tout le
monde
tous ceux qui prétendent en roulant des
mécaniques que ils ont la clé que que
c'est pas difficile il suffit de les
élire on va régler ces questions on
s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas vrai et
deuxièmement pour la France et les
autres pays européens mais
singulièrement pour la France qui est si
proche de l'Italie par par la culture
par l'histoire par la tension par
l'affection
je pense que nous devons participer aux
règlements du problème et donc nous
devons accueillir des migrants c'est pas
ce que je suis en train de dire je vais
essayer de répondre
le ministre de l'Intérieur a dit hier
soir quelque chose d'absolument juste
si je suis bien informé c'est que la
majorité de ces migrants sont
francophones oui il estime que ce sont
des pays qui ne sont pas éligibles au
droit d'Asie
et c'est la chose qu'il convient de
vérifier le plus rapidement possible en
quelques jours
d'où êtes-vous originaire peut-on en
faire la preuve les les voisins les
interprètent tout le monde peut aider à
faire la preuve les migrants qui sont
dans cette situation
d'illégalité je dis ça en sachant
qu'elle misère il fuit
je ne prends pas ça à la légère mais je
sais que les passeurs eux ne sont pas
dans la misère vous dites cela il ne
faudrait passer cela il faut les
raccompagner et il faut les raccompagner
en quelques jours et il faut que
l'Europe tout entière et la France en
tout cas aide l'Italie à les reconduire
ceux qui sont en situation
de
d'asile que l'on doit accueillir selon
nos propres lois et selon les lois
internationales cela il faut qu'en effet
les autres pays européens dont la France
à mes yeux dans la France les aides les
aides à respecter ces engagements je
disais fermeté si je suis tout à fait
précis le ministre de l'Intérieur a
aussi dit que la France
qui travaillent qui ont un travail et
singulièrement dans les métiers en
tension mais il y a aussi d'autres
métiers qui ont un travail qui
apprennent le français
et qui manifeste une volonté
d'intégration c'est à dire de comprendre
qu'en France il y a pas seulement des
droits il y a aussi des devoirs et que
le genre de vie français
ce qui fait notre culture notre manière
d'être
doit être respectée cela on ne peut pas
les laisser dans l'illégalité mais vous
qui travaillez ça seulement pour des
raisons humaines sur des raisons
économiques oui des raisons économiques
mais simplement des raisons d'équilibre
de la société on ne peut pas lorsque
quelqu'un est
participent à la vie du pays on ne peut
pas le renvoyer dans l'illégalité parce
que c'est dans l'illégalité que se passe
les grands désordre la France a besoin
d'immigration demain y compris pour des
raisons d'économie de faire fonctionner
ces entreprises son activité pas
seulement pour ces raisons-là mais de
démographique aussi nous avons un très
grand problème nous avons des problèmes
de déséquilibre dans le travail dans la
démographie et moi je ne veux pas dire
que c'est dans l'immigration que la
solution se trouve parce qu'évidemment
quand vous dites cette phrase
ça ça crée dans un certain nombre de
conscience et d'esprit l'idée que nous
allons désormais dépendre de
l'immigration ça n'est pas ma vision ma
vision à moi c'est que nous devons
dépendre de nous-mêmes
et que c'est dans le dans la vitalité de
de notre peuple de nos concitoyens de
notre natalité à reconquérir dans notre
volonté de produire dans notre volonté
d'inventer c'est là que se trouve la clé
on parle souvent de souveraineté
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire souveraineté
ça veut dire que nous ne dépendons pas
des autres et la clé de notre avenir
elle est uniquement chez nous elle est
dans notre peuple aller dans nos qui
comprennent une politique de natalité
vous souhaiteriez qu'on encourage
davantage natalité absolument convaincu
que l'effondrement de la natalité que
nous sommes en train de vivre ou en tout
cas le déclin de la natalité que nous
sommes en train de vivre et probablement
la plus mauvaise nouvelle que notre
peuple pouvait recevoir de lui-même
parce que c'est c'est nous qui
choisissons ça mais je vais aller une
phrase de plus qui nous relie à d'autres
sujets
les autres pays
tous les autres pays dans le monde
peuvent accepter une baisse de la
natalité pourquoi parce que les autres
pays vivent selon la règle du chacun
pour soi c'est chaque famille qui paie
l'éducation de ses enfants c'est chaque
famille qui prend les assurances
nécessaires pour la santé pour le social
regardez la Suisse le SMIC en Suisse
doit être à 4000 euros mais chacun paie
son éducation c'est
sa retraite ses assurances sociales
évidemment au bout du compte nous
faisons de la solidarité de la
redistribution
seul pays dans le monde à être à ce
point engagé dans cette nécessité de la
solidarité nous nous vivons selon la
règle du tous pour un
et si tous ceux qui
cotisent apportent des ressources à
notre système social à notre système
éducatif à notre système de santé à nos
hôpitaux et si cela devienne de moins en
moins nombreux alors notre contrat
social est insoutenable personne ne se
rend compte de ça personne n'en parle on
fait comme si nous étions assurés à
jamais d'avoir cette règle de solidarité
entre nous elle dépend uniquement où
elle dépendent d'abord de notre capacité
à renouveler tous ceux qui participent à
la solidarité et avoir un pays en
vitalité on a envie de vivre ce que vous
évoquez c'est vraiment pour le coup
l'orientation politique profonde que
l'on souhaite donner au pays un ancien
président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy s'exprime souvent pour donner
son avis son regard hier il l'a fait à
l'occasion d'un déjeuner avec des
députés les républicains sa famille
politique jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
leur donne ce conseil rejoindre
l'exécutif à l'occasion d'un prochain
remaniement et je le cite d'après les
propos qui ont été rapportés une fois à
l'intérieur vous installez un rapport de
force vous obligez Emmanuel Macron à
faire une politique de droite ce qui
n'est pas naturel chez lui qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspire
franchement
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron le contrat
qui a été implicitement signé avec les
Français lorsqu'ils ont choisi c'est au
contraire de ne pas fracturer le pays
entre droite et gauche donc c'est alors
pour moi vous vous savez bien que c'est
le sens de l'engagement de ma vie je ne
crois pas que ce soit d'un bord ou de
l'autre qui a des solutions je pense
qu'il y a des erreurs dans les deux
bords mais je pense que l'avenir du pays
c'est son unité
je peux répéter cette phrase il n'y a
pas d'avenir pour la France si nous ne
faisons pas de l'unité la priorité de
notre engagement commun collectif
citoyens et l'unité ça ne se fait pas en
fracturant le pays en deux et le bloc
central que nous avons constitué au
moment de l'élection de du président de
la République cette majorité qui doit
persister ainsi
elle doit ne pas perdre sa direction et
son orientation alors François ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas
travailler avec la droite ou travailler
avec la gauche
que vous avez sûrement observé mais qui
a pas été commenté il y a un sondage qui
est paru pour la XM X sur demander aux
Français où vous situez-vous à gauche à
l'extrême gauche à gauche au centre pour
la première fois
le choix des Français d'être sans trop
d'être au centre
de réunir les centres pour la première
fois ce choix est désormais majoritaire
à un point 40
42% des Français disent c'est là que
nous voulons être aujourd'hui et ceci
est évidemment une réponse à tous ceux
qui voudraient qu'on revienne aux
anciens clivages qui nous ont fait
beaucoup de mal bien sûr l'une des
préoccupations très terre à terre pour
le coup mais très importantes pour les
Français ce sont les notions de pouvoir
d'achat la première ministre avait
proposé une vente des carburants à perte
par exemple pendant 6 mois selon Bruno
Le Maire les distributeurs de carburant
refusent le PDG de Total Patrick
pouyanet notamment à dire nos confrères
de quotidien qui ne descendraient pas
sous les 1,99 € le litre qui est dans
l'erreur la première mise de l'avoir
proposé les distributeurs de le refuser
bon je crois que la première ministre a
été
[Musique]
s'est vu poser un défi
et a été un peu chahuté par des
déclarations des grands distributeurs
qui disait mais pourquoi nous empêcher
vous de descendre le prix des carburants
laissez-nous vendre à perte
et ces déclarations
l'ont amenées à penser s'ils veulent
vendre à perte qu'il le fasse moi je
crois que la vente à perte n'est jamais
une solution parce que la vente à perte
il y a toujours quelqu'un qui la paix
vous savez ce comment ça se passe dans
la grande distribution ça aurait pu être
les indépendants
vont être les victimes les les stations
services de province aurait été puisque
personne ne le fait les 6000 stations
services ça fait beaucoup quand même ça
fait plusieurs dizaines par départements
vont se trouver les victimes mais c'est
pas l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est
lorsque le distributeur vend le
carburant à perte il se rattrape
et il fait payer sur le reste de
l'alimentation le reste des
ventes
flottante que Jospin avait expérimenté
il y a quelques années c'est un sujet
que j'ai souvent défendu comme vous le
savez notamment au moment des gilets
jaunes je veux faut faire attention sur
ce point
le prix du carburant pour 60% c'est des
taxes
quand vous avez le carburant à 2 euros
les taxes ça représente 30 j'imagine
entre Neurodis et 1,20 quelque chose
comme ça donc évidemment il y a une
responsabilité de l'État aussi mais on
ne peut pas passer sa vie à demander à
l'État de payer
d'améliorer les moyens de l'éducation
d'améliorer d'améliorer les moyens de la
santé de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
davantage d'encadrement des activités de
soutien aux activités d'aider les
entreprises d'aider à l'emploi on peut
pas qu'on ne peut pas lui demander de
dépenser plus dans un pays qui est déjà
en déficit important qu'il y a une
cagnotte de l'État grâce à la mission
Ramos il dit l'état vient de prendre
deux milliards dans la poche des
Français Marine Le Pen sur TF1 lundi
disait il faut restituer 8 milliards et
demi aux Français parce qu'il y a des
rentrées à l'inflation le nombre de ceux
qui se sont des amis pour le nombre de
ceux qui
disent il faut que l'étape
qui sans cesse demande à l'état de
prendre en charge plus de choses dans un
pays dans le déficit est déjà un mal
chronique
vous savez le nombre de dizaines de
milliards de déficits que nous emprunts
tout le monde de lutter contre
l'inflation et c'est pourquoi je vais
demander à notre groupe parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale de préparer ou de
dessiner un plan général de lutte contre
l'inflation en liaison naturellement
avec le gouvernement mais de proposer
des idées sur ce sujet qui ne comportent
pas de baisse des taxes par les temps on
peut décider de baisse de taxes mais
alors il faut décider des baisses de
dépenses
on ne peut pas continuer
j'aurai demain l'occasion de le dire au
corps au Conseil d'orientation des
retraites sur la situation
il se trouve que c'est constamment on se
la France est entrée dans cette culture
de la dépendance à l'état en demandant
en croyant en imaginant bêtement que
l'État peut payer l'État en France et
comme vous le savez endetté plus
qu'aucun autre État européen et la dette
c'est le déficit de tous les ans ce que
nous appelons déficit c'est l'obligation
pour l'État d'emprunter à l'extérieur ce
que il ne peut pas tirer les ressources
pour faire rentrer de l'argent à votre
place il y a quelques jours sur ce
plateau Bruno Le Maire s'est dit
favorable en tout cas il travaille il y
a une taxation des concessions
d'autoroutes peut-être même d'aéroport
est-ce qu'il faut le faire est-ce qu'il
faut taxer les concessions d'autoroute
voir aéroport
vous me ramenez à quelques années en
arrière à quelques années en arrière je
me suis opposé de toutes mes forces à la
privatisation des autoroutes
et que je sache à l'époque si on regarde
qui était au pouvoir
on pourrait sur ce sujet avoir un
sourire
je me suis opposé de toutes mes forces
je suis allé au Conseil d'État contre la
décision de privatisation à titre
personnel je n'ai possédé dans ma vie
que trois actions et c'était trois
actions des sociétés d'autoroute pour
pouvoir aller en justice contre cette
décision là et je savais à l'époque et
j'ai beaucoup dit que il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière alors on peut taxer
des profits qui sont inhabituels
excessifs et ça c'est la responsabilité
de l'État il y a des surprofits pas
seulement dans ce secteur là qui sont
dus ou qui sont augmentés par la crise
et évidemment c'est sur profil-là ne
sont pas moraux mais on aurait vraiment
mieux fait de ne pas privatiser les
sociétés d'autoroute et honoré
maintenant il faut corriger vous voyez
un peu oui bien sûr on peut toujours
dire
non c'est la réalité les bras c'est fait
et il n'aurait pas fallu le faire et la
responsabilité
civique nous nous l'avons assumé j'ai au
nom de de tous ceux qui me soutiennent
conduit le combat jusqu'au bout j'en
suis très fier et on voit aujourd'hui
les dégâts parce que de décisions qui
sont des décisions mauvaises alors on se
retrouve après devant des situations qui
expliquables vous faisiez allés en fait
que donc demain vous êtes entendus par
le comité d'orientation des le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites à votre
demande d'ailleurs je crois vous avez
dit à plusieurs mois déjà que vous aviez
une divergence d'analyses sur ce qui
était la réalité du déficit de notre
système de retraite ce sera quoi ce sera
la leçon du professeur bai ou aux
experts
j'essaie de penser ce qu'une démocratie
juste pour être
une démocratie juste ça devrait être que
l'État dans les décisions qu'il prend
éclairé par des institutions
libres indépendante
partage avec les Français les raisons de
ces choix partage avec les Français
considère les Français comme
co-responsables et leur dit voilà les
raisons je vous donne des documents et
nous allons décider ensemble je pensais
qu'on pouvait gagner un référendum sur
les retraites pourquoi
le corps dit a dit pendant longtemps les
retraites sont équilibrées tu parles
les retraites des Français les pensions
des Français sont financées à 33% par
l'État pour ce qui est en partie de la
fonction publique ou si non non
directement pour la totalité de notre
système de retraite y compris pour les
retraites privées mais si le corps
peut-être le dissoudre alors François
experts en tout cas je trouve que le
rappel à la responsabilité ou l'appel à
la responsabilité qui devrait être notre
ligne de conduite l'appel à la
responsabilité et bienvenue et si les
Français au moment de cette crise des
retraites avait su que nous nous plaçons
dans une situation moralement
scandaleuse dans laquelle vous pensez au
plus jeune générations à nos enfants à
ceux qui vont venir de payer les
retraites d'aujourd'hui pas les
retraites de demain
ce que je ferais entendre sans sujet
aussi très important vous avez organise
de l'éducation en ce moment le sujet du
harcèlement à l'école est au centre de
l'actualité avec plusieurs drames un
fait en particulier à attirer
l'attention cette semaine l'arrestation
dans une salle de classe par les forces
de l'ordre d'un collégien soupçonné de
faits de harcèlement
insultez-moi FOB incitation suicide
devant ses camarades de classe
menottaient qu'est-ce que vous ça vous
inspire
je défends depuis cette époque où
j'étais ministre de l'Éducation l'idée
que l'école doit être un sanctuaire sans
intervention des forces de l'ordre et
les interventions des forces s'il y a
urgence
s'il y a une menace immédiate si on
pense que quelqu'un va faire une très
grosse bêtise instantanément alors c'est
normal qu'on intervienne mais pour le
reste le on peut on peut attendre les
enfants à la sortie de l'école mais ça
n'est pas l'essentiel du problème que
nous visons le problème que nous vivons
c'est que le harcèlement cette
cette solitude extrême à laquelle sont
abandonnés des adolescentes et des
adolescents
qui ne savent pas que en réalité le
harcèlement c'est beaucoup plus large
qu'on ne raconte dans une classe il y a
toujours trois ou quatre élèves ou
peut-être 5 qui sont en situation de
harcèlement pourquoi parce que la
couleur des cheveux parce que le
comportement
c'est le tous ceux qui font le monde de
l'éducation et qui doivent être alertés
et formés sur le fait que il faut
regarder et écouter cet espace
c'est un défi majeur et c'est un devoir
personnel que chacun de ceux qui sont
dans l'école doivent assumer parce qu'il
y a tant d'enfants qui sont en situation
de risque extrême parce qu'il se croit
seul merci beaucoup il se croit seul il
faut les écouter le message est passé
merci d'avoir été sur ce